قالت الشرطه الفرنسيه ابن اربعه اشخاص
بينهم شرطي نصيبوا في عمليه الطعنب بمحطه
قطارات جورجينار بالعاصمه باريس وفقا
للشرطه فان منفذ الهجوم استخدم السكيلا
قبل ان يسارع رجال الشرطه الى اطلاق النار
على صدره ونقل على اثر ذلك للمستشفى وهو
في حاله حرجه وقد اكد وزير الداخليه
الفرنسيه ان القوات الامن استجابت بسرعه
للعمليه والقت القبض على منفذ الهجوم
من اصابه سته اشخاص كانوا قريبين منه
احدهم شرطي وهناك اخر حالته خطره حتى الان
لا نعرف دوافع المهاجم الذي لم يكن يحمل
اوراق ثبوتيه ولم نتعرف عليه بعد
من امام محطه في باريس مراسل الجزيره نور
الدين بوزيان لم يكن لدى المهاجم بطاقه
هويه ولا شيء معروفا عنه هل هنالك تفاصيل
عن الملابسات كيف طارد الناس هل هتفا
بهتافات معينه او اي شيء من هذا القبيل
وزير الداخليه سئل قبل نحو ساعتين من الان
خلف هنا فقال بان فلم يؤكد ان يكون تم او
يكون ردد الجاني اي كلام همم طبعا همم
الجرح سته فقط منفذ العمليه الذي يوجد
وفقا تصريح من ادنى به قبل قليل المتحدث
باسم محافظه الشرطه هنا في باريس هو الذي
يوجد في حاله الخطر ايضا بدات تعرف بعض
تعبير بعض المعلومات عن الجاني لم تذكر
طبعا حسب ما تسرب من نقابه الشرطه الذين
يتواجدون منذ هذا الصباح خلفي بان الرجل
المعتدي على حد تعبيرهم همم يبلغ من العمر
تقريبا 30 عاما لم ترشح لحد الان معلومات
عن هويته ملامحه هل يسكن باريس هل جاء من
خارج باريس تعرف جيدا بهذه المحطه
باليوميا 700,000 مسافر زين
ايضا استبعدت حتى هذه اللحظه اذكر حتى هذه
اللحظه استعد ما يسمى بالفرضيه التي ربما
تذهب بالتحقيق باتجاه العمل الارهابي خلفي
لعلك تشاهد زيت
نور الدين حركتها العاديه استبعدت ام انها
لم تعلم بعد لحد هذه اللحظه
حتى هذه اللحظه زين وسيكون دقيقا في كلامي
حتى هذه اللحظه الناقبي في الشرطه وايضا
جهات اخرى لا استطيع ان اذكرها حتى هذه
اللحظه تقول بان الفرضيه الارهابيه
مستبعده حتى هذه اللحظه والدليل على ذلك
زين بان الذي الجهه التي الان تجري او
تجري التحريات والتحقيقات هي الشرطه
القضائيه وتعريف جيدا عاده عندما تظهر
اولى يعني المؤشرات عندما يكون الامر عمل
الارهابي الجهه المكلفه بالتحقيق تعلن
رسميا من قبل السلطات هنا هي الجهه
المكلفه بمحاربه الارهاب فقط وذكر بان
التفاصيل ستصلنا ولا شك وسنعرفها بعد اقل
من ساعتين عندما تعقد المدعيه العامه هنا
في باريس مؤتمر صحفيا ولا شك ان الكثير من
الامور تتضح خلفي بالنسبه لعمليه او لحركه
همم النقل داخل هذه المحطه الكبيره
اذكر بان لا يزال هناك حتى هذه اللحظه زين
ما يسمى بالمربع الامني همم طبعا نوع من
الشرائط التي توضع في فضاء معين ويكتب
عليها الشرطه ويطلب من الماره او الاشخاص
الا يجتازوا هذه المنطقه وطبعا حركه
القطارات عادت الى طبيعتها منذ تقريبا
ساعه وخاصه باتجاه لندن حيث كانت توقفت
هذا الصباح منذ العمليه توقفت حركه النقل
بين باريس ولندن وبين بعض الوجهات في
اوروبا الغربيه تحديدا هولندا وايضا
المانيا وبلجيكا
نور الدين همم يا ابو زيان من الامام محطه
باريس براس الجزيره شكرا لك